hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome attacking game that was played
in 2003 in the hunger hotel super chess
tournament
it's a weird name i know but um they
didn't seem to mind and here judith
pogar faces hungarian grandmaster ferenz
berkesh
in uh really just a a crushing attack if
you will
and there will be a couple of great
positive video moments three of them
uh because you this attacks are
extremely fierce and you uh constantly
have to find
what's happening here so uh without
further ado let's check it out and see
what
uh what happened in this game and thank
you uh to branch out
for uh recommending this game it's
really an awesome one so uh hopefully
you guys will enjoy it as well
uh so ud with the white pieces opens
with e4
uh we have e6 uh berkeley goes for the
french defense we have d
for d5 knight to c3 and now knight to f6
going for the classical variation we
have bishop to g5
pinning the knight preparing e5 and now
d captures an e4 we have knight
characters and bishop to e7 now
defending the knight now black
is threatening to capture this knight on
e4 uh so you did captures on f6 bishop
captures bishop captures
and now uh this pawn is attacked twice
so just defend while developing
knight to f3 so making sure uh you
constantly
develop your pieces as uh you know
morphy taught us all
we have castles and the queen to d2
again developing
and preparing the castle queen side
which immediately brings another
attacker into the game we have knight to
d7
and now queen side castles uh we have
bishop
back to e7 uh and now comes bishop to d3
and here b6 black wants to develop his
light square bishop to this long
diagonal
uh and here there are some games where
h4 was played where you just want to
start pushing that phone right away but
here you it goes for knight e to g5 now
with the threat of just picking up the
h7 pawn
berkus says uh that's not really doing
anything let's just play h6 so now
it doesn't really matter h7 square there
there's no pawn there
but you did goes bishop to h7 with check
king to h8 and
now bishop back to e4 so putting
pressure on that rook on a8 and
the knight is still hanging here so what
do you play here you could
capture the knight or you could move the
rook so here uh
capturing uh rook to b8 is a known move
it's been it's been played but
here h captures and g5 has also been
played but
only in this game and one modern game
from 2019 so
uh we're going to discuss that but now
it's a really tricky position how do you
continue this position with white and
this is only the first of the three
positive video moments we're to have in
this game
because it's such a such a wild
attacking game so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the absolute best way to
continue the attack for you
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
not playing h4 h4 or capturing the rook
capturing rook or h4 that's not how we
how we do it on this channel
uh here uh g4 is the move and this is uh
very important uh to give you a
demonstration if you play h4 then you
basically give black uh all the options
in the world black can just play g4
you're never going to open up the h file
for for your rook and now uh what do you
play
you could grab the rook but just bishop
the a6 and still the knight is under
attack now the bishop is under attack
once the bishop moves we're just gonna
pick up the piece
and after the bishop moves let's say
knight f6 and we're perfectly happy
playing this position we're up
material and white doesn't really have
any way of attacking the black king
so what you have to do here after this
capture
is play g4 now ud is saying now i'm
gonna play h4 on the next move and your
pawn is stuck here so i'm definitely
opening up the h file
so here the game continued uh we have
rooked the b8 black saves the rook now
but now h4 uh and now of course uh
you you could capture and claim that
your queen and bishop are guarding pawn
but just g5 and next you're going to
capture here so there's no way of
keeping the h file closed
so instead after h4 we have g6 making
some reading room for the king here on
g6
and now comes h captures on g5
opening up a discovery from the rook
here we've kinked the g7
and now comes queen to f4 another very
deadly move
uh threatening some very nasty ideas uh
and here
uh there is one game uh that i mentioned
the modern game where rook the h8 was
played in that game ended in a draw but
this game from 2003
where bishop to b7 uh was played uh most
certainly did not end in a draw so now
bishop to b7
uh threatening to to take out one uh one
of the attackers but you guys are
here to help you feel free to pause the
video for a second time and find the
winning idea while i give you a couple
of seconds
again
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding the only
move that successfully continues the
attack for white and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
rook to h7 with check that's the good
stuff that's why the queen came to f4 so
you could sacrifice the rook and then
you have
this check and then you can bring the
queen to h6
if needed so here you have to capture it
if you don't capture it's flicking to
jade then just rook d
to h1 and you are very quickly getting
checkmated here
so instead after this rook to h7
king captures on h7 was played but now
comes queen to h2 with
check and now we have to go to g8 if you
go to g7 then it's just queen to h6
checking the g8 and now
this bishop captures on g6 very nasty
idea
uh and here after f captures we're going
to play queen captures king h8 and rook
to h1
checkmate so there's even that so
instead after queen to h2 check we have
king to g8
now the queen coming here will not come
with check
but here udit uh still plays it because
it
uh comes with it with an unstoppable
idea we have rook
d to h1 now threatening both queen h7
and queen to h8
checkmate and there's only one move
black and play basically to prevent mate
and that is bishop captures on g5 with
check and now again
uh there's the question of how do you
play this uh
once again pause the video here and try
to find the winning idea for white
it's not a simple one well i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those who are able to do it
congratulations on capturing on
g5 i know this is probably the the first
thing you thought of but then you were
like nah that's that's
probably not we have to move our king
the problem is if you play king to b1
uh yes it seems like you're still
enjoying the same threats but
there's a problem here uh what if you
play king to g7
and now how do you how do you win this
now the rook regards this square
uh and if you bring the queen to h7 then
the king escapes king f6
we're gonna capture here on g5 but we
don't care
bishop captures here knight captures an
e4 with
king e7 and now after queen to h for
check we're just gonna play king to e8
and our king is very much safe here
we're up a whole rook and we're gonna
win this game
and another thing after bishop captures
on g5 if you go king to d1
uh it's not much better i mean it's uh
pretty much
the same thing so what you would have to
do here is just
capture the bishop and now it works
because now after queen captures with
check
now we block with f4 uh you could uh
for example uh you you couldn't block
with the f4 because the knight here so
capturing with the knight
also comes in handy in freeing up the
pawn to be pushed to f4
and now there really isn't anything you
can do here just uh
queen h7 or queen to h it will be
checkmate and while you can resign here
uh maybe you could try and play this
game king g7 maybe still try to escape
but it still doesn't matter just
checking if six we're going to pick up
the queen king e7
and we're even gonna pick up the bishop
here after rook captures it's a queen
and rook against two rooks a knight but
it's an
ugly position for black black could
maybe play this you know
and hope for something but uh you know
that doesn't really make sense
so here uh black just captured on f4 and
here he allowed you to
uh just win the game on the spot so here
now now it's uh
uh check so you can't deliver checkmate
so queen captures was played we have
bishop captures and now queen captures
on e4
and he was in this position on 24 that
ferenz berkus resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so really a wild attacking game and it
really took
a lot of unique moves because in all of
these positions for example here
after this uh bishop to e4 you really
have to find
this g4 moved in order to continue the
attack it's not uh
incredibly difficult because you know if
you push h4 your opponent will play g4
but still you have to find g4
uh then you had to find after bishop to
b7 you had to find this beautiful rook
to h7 sacrifice
and then again you had an opportunity to
make a mistake here after bishop
captures on g5 if you just move the king
you have to capture and then block with
f4 so those were the
three obstacles that you know uh were in
front of you this game and hopefully you
resolved all of them and you
uh achieved a great victory alongside
unit
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it really really an impressive win for
you that and if you're wondering how you
did in this tournament we do have the
standings here or
rather i hope we do yeah we do uh yeah
we have the standings of the hung west
uh
hunger hotels super chess tournament
yeah that's a great name
uh so there you have it uh in nigel
short won the third
won the tournament with six and a half
out of nine he uh won uh
uh his encounter against judith uh
you're with five and a half of peter
lako who defeated
udit uh is in third place half point
behind you then we have
christopher lutz peter axe boris
girlfriend viktor korchnoy sergey
mustaci and fergus
ferenz berkel uh so a lot
a lot of really strong players and the
big names that
you did left behind and uh well
it was only nigel short who uh stood in
her way
yeah to grab first place but really
really an impressive game thank you for
suggesting it
and again it shows the the power of
hashtag suggestion because i'm only one
person there are many of you and
there will always be games uh that we
will enjoy
seeing that i might not even be aware of
so thank you for suggesting them
uh so uh once again hope you guys
enjoyed that i would like to thank
alexander williamson derek king jorge
campos
david trainer and kevin stormeier for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
such as this one and whatever else
happens in the chess world
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day